le point est donc ce très physique le
plus susceptible de devenir une source
d'alimentation
on a tendance à percevoir le poids comme
une chose qu'on peut contrôler or si une
personne est grosse ce n'est pas pauvre
toi mais plutôt qu'est ce que tu fais
pour être aussi gros ou aussi grosse se
profiler de par les contacts qu'on ait
eue avec les rendre école c'est que
possiblement enfin le profane caracal
échec personnel pour laquelle on est
plus intolérante façon générale comme
société finale alors c'est comme si ça
justifie d'une certaine façon le fait
qu'on leur fait d'intimidation à nier
mais l'université du québec en outaouais
vient de compléter avec son équipe une
recherche importante qui établit un lien
direct entre le problème de surpoids
chez les jeunes et les incidents
d'intimidation et avec sa femme dans la
cour d'école faveur que si le jeune est
en fait sans doute de sa faute des
pauvres et des pôles quoi mais est ce
qui est quand même en fait dans la loi
on mentionne des caractéristiques
physiques
donc j'en déduis que des
caractéristiques physiques inclut le
poids et le surpoids
par contre on ne mentionne pas
spécifiquement
alors je voulais que les taux d'accès
qui a été conduite avec l'association
présentait que d'ex québec visé à mettre
en relief le fait que ben c'est une
préoccupation vraiment bien présente
dans les cours d'écoles secondaires et
qu'on devrait donc regarder ça de plus
près tout peut-être même songé à
l'inclure précisément comment on fait
avec
la déficience intellectuelle ou les
problèmes physiques ou d'autres
vous êtes peut-être déjà passé par là
les conséquences de l'intimidation par
rapport aux points peuvent être graves
baisse de l'estimé de soins isolement
dépression anxiété et troubles
alimentaires notamment en rack ont su
l'htv statistiques nouvelles concernant
la croissance du nombre d'enfants obèses
au canada les victimes potentielles
apparaissent de plus en plus nombreuses
les enfants canadiens sont parmi les
moins en forme
selon un tout récent rapport de
participaction menée dans 38 pays
le rapport relève notamment le manque
d'activité physique et le comportement
sédentaire de notre jeunesse canadienne
les enfants n'ont pas oublié comment
jouer un enfant sera toujours comment
jouer c'est peut-être plus à haut niveau
du rôle de l'adulte qui est qui a évolué
dernièrement où l'adulte veut toujours
occuper ses enfants faut toujours que
lui et un intérêt pour le jeu de
l'enfant qu'il y ait qui dirige un petit
peu lent de cartes et de la vie de
l'enfant est né n'est pas à l'aise en
fait avec le fait que l'enfant joue tout
seul et puis jouer un petit peu à ce
qu'il veut mathieu points et professeur
au département des sciences de
l'éducation de l'université du québec à
trois rivières une ville située entre
montréal et québec
c'est vraiment quand quel adulte qui
initie jeu pour l'enfant qui prépare une
activité c'est lui qui en charge un
petit peu et l'enfant ne fait que suivre
les instructions de l'adulte quand on
parle de jeux libres fait un petit peu
ce que ce que certains auteurs
considèrent comme le vrai jeu entre
guillemets le jeu où l'enfant décide par
lui-même à quoi il va jouer avec quoi il
va jouer où il va jouer et avec qui va
jouer c'est lui qui aimait mettre un
petit peu de sa situation de jeu et
plusieurs études démontrent que c'est
lors du jeu lire que l'enfant est plus
active te manque d'activité physique
chez les jeunes b directement lié avec
un manque de jeux libres un petit peu
actuellement les enfants sont très
structurés dans leurs activités
actuellement on est dans une société qui
est vraiment poussé vers la performance
dans l'excellent succès tu as donc les
parents ont tendance à vouloir à tout
prix que leurs enfants sachent lire
écrire des plus jeune âge mais quand on
connaît un petit peu les phases de
développement de l'enfant mais on s'en
rend compte que trop tôt c'est pas
forcément du bon que en bas âge ont
jusqu à 5 6 dans le jeu libre est
vraiment favorable au développement de
l'enfant plus que les activités
structurées si la discrimination sur la
base du point semble être le premier
facteur qui déclenche les attaques
discriminatoire l'orientation sexuelle
serait l'autre grand corridor le plus
fréquenté par les intimidateurs la
violence des passes alors des cours de
récréation à l'espace web
près de la moitié des victimes seraient
de jeunes hommes
les cas de ces extorsions sont en forte
hausse au canada depuis 2003 2004
il s'agit d'une méthode d'extorsion par
laquelle un individu en ligne sur les
réseaux sociaux enregistre secrètement
une personne après l'avoir incité à se
déshabiller ou à poser des gestes
intimes devant une webcam
l'arnacoeur utilise ensuite ces images
pour extorquer de l'argent à sa victime
en la menaçant de diffuser la vidéo
personne de confiance alors que le ter
aux 4 5 semaines d'utilisation
la grande majorité des jeunes ont dit
avoir brisé science avec une personne de
confiance
la chercheuse isabelle ouellette morin
et son équipe de l'institut
universitaire en santé mentale de
montréal ont développé une application
mobile interactive qui permet aux jeunes
victimes d'intimidation de comprendre ce
qu'ils subissent et qui les outils pour
réagir à ces agressions examen empirique
initial
on prête au jeu et pourquoi aborder lors
et de danse et ensuite après 4 les mêmes
questionnaire est le premier élément de
réponse et qu' il dise rapporte une
diminution de 4 50% des expériences
intimidations lorsque suite avec donc
l'idée c'est d'avoir une vision plus
juste objective de ce qu'ils écrivent
pour les aider à régler des priorités
pour initier des stratégies
opportunistes un film et c'est donc à
savoir les accompagner dans la une
certaine de démarches pour pouvoir
trouver des stratégies qui sont les
causes de cris pour eux pour tomber
l'accusation
un reportage de radio canada
international